bonjour à toutes et à tous l'invité de
sa organise ce matin 4 infitran bonjour
bonjour jour aux auditeurs de martinique
première déléguée académique aux
relations européennes internationales et
à la coopération alors jusqu'au 2
octobre
on se déroule élise il ira ce midi alors
erasmus plus qu'est ce que c'est alors
les erasmus des fêtes viennent célébrer
finalement les plus de 30 ans du
programme emblématique européen le
programme communautaire erasmus qui
permet donc depuis 30 ans maintenant à
des générations d'étudiants d'élèves de
personnel de partir en mobilité en
europe
d'accord comment ça se passe à partir de
quel âge et à quel moment on peut partir
dans les pays européens
alors en fait le programme erasmus est
un programme qui a qui s'appelle donc
depuis 2014 erasmus plus être un
programme en fait qui regroupe un
ensemble de public et donc de la
maternelle jusqu'à l'université
ce programme permet donc aux
établissements scolaires aux universités
donc il est surtout connu notamment dans
son volet universitaire tu te feu mais
il est important en fait je crois
aujourd'hui que nous sachions que ça
concerne différents publics
les stages et de la formation
professionnelle les universités a certes
les élèves et l'ensemble des personnels
de l'établissement scolaire
alors c'était le sens de ma prochaine
question sa sas ainsi tant sur plusieurs
volets il ya plusieurs personnes il ya
plusieurs j'ai plusieurs élèves qui sont
concernés ça va de la maternelle vous
disiez à aux étudiants par exemple en
maternelle qu à quel moment intervient
il reste plus alors en fait erasmus
intervient dans son volet de partenariat
un partenariat stratégique dans le cadre
d'une action de l'attraction que les
deux puisque ea là il y en a 3 au niveau
du programme erasmus plus donc ça permet
donc aux écoles primaires de mettre nos
enfants en relation avec le monde et
avec l'europe et ça se passe
généralement de manière virtuelle 1
puisque il n'est pas encore question
pour des petites manières de se déplacer
mais en fait cette ouverture
sur l'europe et plus largement sur le
monde est possible via notamment la
mobilité virtuelle est ce que dans le
hold up sur une chanson sont poursuis le
cursus au collège ce qu'il ya des
déplacements qui sont liées parce que je
croyais aussi des classes européennes
qui font aussi des déplacements est ce
que tout ça ça rentre dans la semaine
mais tout ça c'est en fait voilà ça
concourt en fait des mêmes objectifs
il s'agit pour l'europe un don qui
contribue très largement au financement
de ces mobilités dans cuillère pour dire
le programme européen ce sont 14
milliards d'euros qui ont été actés par
l'europe entre 2014 et 2020 t1 dans la
mesure où ce sont des programmations de
7 ans et elle permet effectivement à des
élèves de collèges de pouvoir dans le
cadre d'un projet qui sera porté par
leur établissement de partir en europe
pour rencontrer leurs homologues
échanger s'ouvrir pratiquer les
différentes langues européennes alors
aux mains teennick là on avait su on
revient sur le voulais sur le cursus des
étudiants combien d'étudiants ont pu
bénéficier dire est ce plus plus est-ce
que vous avez un chiffre donc en fait
c'est vrai que dans le cadre de ces
erasmus 10 en fait nous sommes sur une
coorganisation 1 ça concerne à la fois
l'université des antilles donc
l'université des antilles accueil et
mobilise largement le programme erasmus
plus et ce sont plus de 200 étudiants
internationaux qui peuvent en bénéficier
sachant que la l'académie l'université
accueille cette année par exemple une
soixante dix étudiants européens un cari
d'allemagne de la république tchèque et
c'est pour ce qui y est donc de notre
deuxième partenaire qui est l'école de
gestion et de commerce de la martinique
il participe également à cette mobilité
entrante avec des échanges en fait donc
des semestre des changes pour des
étudiants européens qui viennent
au niveau de l'école de gestion et de
commerce de la martinique notamment sur
des étudiants allemands et par ailleurs
nous avons dans le cadre de la mobilité
sortante haut niveau donc du rectorat
par exemple ce sont plus de 300 jeunes
qui partent chaque année dans le cadre
donc de la mobilité des motifs de
mobilité de stage d'accord alors dans
quel d'un tel pays
quels sont les pays les plus prisés
alors bien sûr les pays les plus prisées
restent l'espagne pour la plupart le
royaume uni mais jusqu'au break site
parce que je pourrais en parler c'est un
vrai faux c'est un vrai problème le la
question du break site et donc et puis
donc depuis quelques temps nous avons
également une diversification donc rdd
mobilité vers l'allemagne il ya des
mobilités également vers malte qui vient
en fait supplanter ou se substituer en
deux au royaume uni il ya des piles
émergents ou dans en europe qui sont
aussi vus ou bien qui attire le nos
jeunes mais en fait je crois que nos
jeunes sont également attirés et sa sous
l'impulsion des des enseignants par des
destinations comme l'europe
les pays nordiques nous avons par
exemple des étudiants qui sont partis et
or faire leur stage en entreprise en
hollande
les étudiants du lycée aliker par
exemple dans le cadre de leur filière
transport et logistique dont vous avez
donc les pays nordiques les pays de
l'est également je crois que la roumanie
constitue aujourd'hui un vrai pôle
d'attraction pour pour nos élèves et nos
étudiants d'accord alors dans quel
domaine
alors on a parlé des formations la
poursuite des études menées alors dans
quel dans quels secteurs dans quel
domaine
généralement ces jeunes vont poursuivre
ou bien vont se former mais en fait
c'est vrai que c'est très varié puisque
nous avons à la fois donc des mobilités
d'études donc qu'ils vont se faire pour
nos étudiants ce soit en allemagne au
royaume uni et sera donc ça ça ça relève
plus de l'université et donc ses
fonctions effectivement de l'appétence
et différentes filières que là que
l'université va vouloir mettre en
exergue par ailleurs pour ce qui est des
mobilités de stage bien ça va du
commerce en passant par je parlais tout
à l'heure de transport et logistique ou
encore de l'informatique voilà donc les
filières sont vraiment très variés - je
cherche un stage alors peu importe le
domaine comment je dois me prendre comme
en jeu droit quel cheminement je dois
faire pour obtenir une partie ressources
ou effacement alors le programme erasmus
plus va répondre en fait à un besoin à
une demande qui aura été repéré au sein
de l'établissement
1 parce qu'il n'ya pas de mobilité
possible de manière individuelle de 1 ce
sont deux voilà ce sont des projets qui
sont portées par à des structures et
donc là le jeune qui est intéressé va se
rapprocher de son établissement va se
rapprocher de l'université donc le
bureau des relations internationales de
l'université
le service des relations internationales
de l'eau jc et les autres structures
parce qu'effectivement il y à le voler
c'est éducation formation mais a
également volé qui est important
jeunesse et sports avec encore on voit
que voilà qui est encore trop trop
méconnu sur notre territoire
et puis nom pareil à les stagiaires de
la formation professionnelle je sais que
le pôle emploi également son volet
les opci de martinique mobilisent par
endroits le de l'erasmus plus fait tout
ça pour dire que de toute façon les
projets sont portés par une institution
d'accord et comment se passe le
financement ce financement il est à
hauteur généralement erasmus l'usva
financiers autour des 60 70 % une bourse
par exemple pour vous dire vous donner
une idée une bourse pour une placement
stages donnent étudiants de bts de 9
semaines et qui vaut à peu près le
montant un photogramme mobilité c'est à
peu près 4000 voire 5000 euros et
erasmus va abonder à hauteur de pas loin
de 4000 euros
donc c'est vraiment des financements
très important et que notre télé 3 a
tout intérêt à mobiliser alors on
revient sur le brésil
quelles conséquences pourrait avoir le
bric site sur rue erasmus plus mais en
fait la question de la caisse sur la
question reste entière un parce que pour
le moment il s'agit pour les pays qui
l'ont qui ont déjà entamé des échanges
et des partenariats avec le royaume uni
de poursuivre en fait jusqu'à la fin du
programme
là je revienne séminaire à bordeaux et
l' agence nationale
la question reste entière que deviendra
erasmus plus sans le royaume uni qui est
un pays qui contribue énormément donc
mais tout cela reste pour le moment très
floue tout ce que l'europe espère c'est
que la sortie du break ci dessous se
fasse de manière consentie est-ce qu'on
jusque on joue la survie même du
programme alors je ne suis pas en mesure
de répondre précisément sur cela mais je
pense que le programme
il est un programme ancré c'est un
programme emblématique et il va à coup
sûr demeurer au-delà effectivement des
problématiques liées aux breaks site
vous allez vous allez vous avez parlé
également dix jeunes de la jeunesse et
des sports comment ils rasmussen
entre au-dessus programme dans ces
structures aussi les associations qui
peuvent bénéficier d'erasmus oui tout à
fait donc il y a donc je disais donc
trois volets dont erasmus on est à la
fois le volet éducation formation le
volet jeunesse le volet sport et ses
volets sont développées et portait en
tout cas localement par les associations
comme les cemea la djs et s est une
porte d'entrée
justement de l'ensemble des associations
qui sont en mesure de mobiliser ces
fonds erasmus plus pour permettre à la
jeunesse martiniquaise de partir se
former s'enrichir s'ouvrir et puis
développer les compétences transversales
que nous connaissons aujourd'hui alors
par exemple dans le sport comment une
association sportive peut bénéficier ccl
un projet poursuit pas formés ou bien
apporter un plus à ses seins c'est à
dire en elle peut se faire bénéficier
elle peut bénéficier des restaurants
absolument les associations toutes les
associations telles qu'elles soient deux
territoires peuvent en montant des
projets bénéficier donc des fois erasmus
plus pour permettre à la fois
d'accueillir dans le cadre des échanges
de jeunes par exemple accueillir des
jeunes européens et permettre aux autres
de partir se former et généralement ça
se fait énormément en lien avec les
collectivités puisque le principe même
des fonds européens si celui du co
financement
donc voilà est généralement dans les
collectivités que ce soit les mairies
que ce soit les opci ou encore la
collectivité territoriale de martinique
sont de très précieux partenaires pour
l'ensemble de ceux qui mobilisent de
l'erasmus plus autre chose grâce mus
existe également pour les jeunes
entrepreneurs c'est une nouveauté
alors en fait celle ce programme il a
été lancé dès d'amy et 2014
mais c'est vrai que en termes de
communication aujourd'hui il
il demeure encore peu connu et c'est un
projet qui en fait un programme qui est
porté et diffuser promu par la cci de là
d'un martinique et donc et donc
d'ailleurs baisse matin il ya un petit
déjeuner à l'école de gestion et de
commerce de la martinique à l'adresse
des jeunes entrepreneurs et de manière à
ce qu'ils puissent effectivement prendre
connaissance et s'emparer finalement de
six opportunités qui sont offertes
ça veut dire que moi j'ai déjà mon
entreprise mais que je besoin de
compléments de formation et je peux
bénéficier à travers ce programme via ce
programme je peux bénéficier donc il ya
des réseaux d'entreprises qui vont
pouvoir par le biais donc du programme
bien être en synergie pour accueillir et
aider en fait finalement ces jeunes
entrepreneurs à monter en compétences
alors on va rappeler les lits les
grandes dates parce que il ya ça va se
dérouler jusqu'au 12
quelles sont les grandes manifestations
que vous allez organiser alors nous
sommes dans une coorganisation l
université des antilles le gc et le
rectorat de martinique et c'est avec le
point d'orgue de ces erasmus des se
trouvera demain donc demain matin de 8
heures jusqu'à 13 heures toute la
matinée
nous allons donc alors nous avons hockey
organisé différents volets de manière à
ce que la population puisse
universitaires étudiants tous scolaires
enfin bref le grand public qui pourrait
être intéressé dans la mesure où il ya
un village européen il y aura ce qu'on
appelle le babel café ou des jeunes
européens qui sont ici présents ou
encore représentants d'une langue
européenne pourront s'exprimer et dire
pourquoi ils sont sur notre territoire
parce qu'il faut aussi voilà bien noter
que ce type de programme par anticipe
très largement à au développement de
l'attractivité de notre territoire et de
développement l'on se passe ou ça se
passe sur le campus sa spatiaux le
campus de schoelcher très bien erasmus
bien sur europe1 programme simuler en
faveu que pour la caraïbe
beh oui en fait nous y travaillons
fortement dans la mesure où
l'internationalisation du programme
erasmus plus ce n'est pas encore une
vraie réalité sauf sur la partie
enseignement supérieur et c'est pour
cela qu'au niveau donc du rectorat de
l'académie de au rectorat nous avons
développé en fait un projet qui
s'appelle et l'on sait échanges
linguistiques pour l'apprentissage
novateur par la mobilité et qui est un
projet qui est financé très largement
par un programme européen que nous
connaissons qui est le programme
interreg caraïbes et ce programme a pour
objectif de permettre que plus de 3000
public en fait différents publics
puisqu'il s'agit à la fois de scolaires
d'étudiants d'universitaires et des
stagiaires de la formation
professionnelle de manière à ce qu'on
puisse aller vers d'autres territoires
proches qu'à la caraïbe merci madame
sizeranne je vous remercie bonne journée
à l écoute de nos programmes